question pour toi
quel est le nom du nouveau souverain
d'Angleterre qui succède à la reine
Elizabeth II on va voir si tu peux être
Miss Charles
[Applaudissements]
III
perdues pour l'instant toi tu es éliminé
tu seras jamais mis de toute façon je
pense que c'était pas dans tes projets
Géraldine quel joueur de football a
remporté le Ballon d'Or 2022 c'est une
question qui est tombée au questionnaire
bravo
merci et eux ils ont des ils ont des
propositions
les mecs mais alors c'était après je
trouve ça normal
tu me dis si tu me manque juste les
nichons et après c'est bon quoi ça se
fait Benjamin quel cours se nautique à
voix les parties ce 6 novembre 2022 à
destination de Pointe-à-Pitre la Route
du Rhum
[Applaudissements]
questionnaire Miss France ils ont eu
cette question aussi quelle fan de
l'être française a été nommée prix Nobel
de littérature en 2022 Annie Ernaux
Virginie Despentes et ma Becker au
Brigitte Giraud exactement
la fête de la musique a eu 40 ans cette
année à quelle ancien ministre doit-on
cette fête
la langue la langue Jacques Duhamel
Frédéric Mitterrand Catherine trocman
ensuite en Suisse pour parler d'économie
mondiale archam à Charmed chèque en
Égypte pour parler de l'environnement ou
à Doha au Qatar pour parler de la coupe
du monde de foot
de manière convaincue ça passait
maintenant
j'ai la bonne réponse j'ai pas de
m'embrouiller hein
c'est bon
non merci
il a présenté une émission hier ça y est
ok
après le calendrier
[Applaudissements]
et après le calendrier
mais qui a déjà entendu cette balle à
l'école et
après on est mardi dans ta gueule
ouais BIM c'est la saint Fernand c'est
violent hein
de quel pays venaient les trois
dernières Miss Univers Afrique du Sud
Venezuela Mexique France Afrique du Sud
Inde Mexique Venezuela Inde Afrique du
sud du Mexique facile c'est très
difficile je vais dire là là
l'occasion
tu as perdu l'occasion de fermer ta
gueule qui a écrit la pièce Cyrano de
Bergerac
[Applaudissements]
la tirade du NON MERCI la plus belle
sirène merci merci
sans mentir si votre Puma
que par ton au Rambo là
c'est bon
c'est pour toi sont pré original et de
200 € combien coûte la paire après
remise 70 €, 140 € 120 € 130 € 130 €
bravo bravo
les mecs c'est juste une barre de fer on
le sait tous ici donc sur l'oseille
voilà Cathy comment s'appelle le volcan
de la Guadeloupe le Merapi la montagne
Pelée la Soufrière
on dit la python de la Fournaise le
python bah oui ou Daniel Moreau le
Daniel Moreau également les Piton de la
Fournaise
bon alors voilà et le questionnaire est
comporté 40 questions il fallait 40
minutes pour y répondre c'est pas
évident
c'est pas si facile donc pour mieux être
Miss France il faut pouvoir répondre à
tout ça